I think we should get married are you
what I should give them out I want to be
in the now and in and how can I marry at
least you break up what can what I'm
talking about forget it forget it
[Music]
yeah I'd like to be there really really
don't go just don't tell me you guys
were inseparable do you remember that
well at a long time ago a year and a
half hits a jog my memory
we're having this dinner party tonight
maybe you want to come Adam and Alison
used to go out
no that literally right before Erin Erin
I think it's so cool that you can it's
really big a few things we're both big
what I've actually a very small penis
really no no oh
so funny running into I work here for
seven years and I just stick it out and
bite you or I never see you again
hey I'm coming okay come in the wedding
good
baby please oh yeah it for a while wait
we do it
he's actually a really cool guy sorry I
don't forget married your girlfriend
getting black Sophie that's mrs. Oh
speak now or forever hold your peace
[Music]
you